here we go again against the albert
minus eight my squats not really
improving 24 wins 32 losses seven
drawers ok I'll try something new why it
hasn't played much just just go for
super solid development I recently saw
that this line is reasonably popular
even here in this move order with them
with e3 being possible was surprised to
see that but blacks results are really
ok so he maybe wants to close the
position down not sure if this is good
way I can take only five no maybe hmm
hmm yeah i'm just experimenting yeah
with this setup i have no idea how the
how the plans are I just know that they
go Bishop c5 a 6 and so on it looks a
little bit passive here at the moment
yeah I could loopy 8 has some kind of
small strengthening what is this idea
Bishop e3 and then maybe before no this
one okay the idea now my idea is to take
and play now he closes it down okay
interesting question where to put it
here I think I'll go here and you can go
where forward this is not so so clear if
it is if it is that great I have some
counter ideas like Nigerian and some
cases night age for my bishop 187 is a
pretty good PCF I've looked at some
similar positions for my book project
out of them out of the logo and it is in
fact not that easy to play it quite
often so here Knight g4 takes Queen age
for Bishop 83 is not doing much night
each for might be a move
okay let's go let's go Quincy eight set
nettles I look sad looks awfully slow
very slow
if i go back to age 74 taking i don't
think that this helps okay maybe ah
queen age five I I don't Wow it doesn't
react to it at all okay okay maybe it so
it's just bad i mean it's it's possible
yes fif but that I wasn't completely
convinced about
f6 king of seven rugae jade has my plan
what is your plan on a very good day
bishop d for 25 but or Bishop e3 a form
that would be really nice that this
should be still a monster on 87 that's a
very good position for black actually he
has a he has a hard time now him maybe
he can play I can oh um unless you can
trade earthquake and can catch my queen
that's my that's of course possible
maybe night h5 but Roxy for is not a
threat really isn't okay so let's let's
continue with my plan king of seven rook
age 8 simple chess is got 94 maybe
coming anyway this is this is the move
okay I cannot sacrifice here
doubling doubling be cute not sure if it
lets much cannot go g6 here okay I still
do it am i threatening this now Queen g4
takes rook edge to check back on f1 no
nights no threat it is a threat if he
goes night to eat six
I wonder if g6 is suicidal here or not
might be okay if I take now wait to f1
no okay
not sure she thinks it's good but I
don't want to draw here want to fight
let's see what is he doing this one hmm
didn't see that one coming Bishop Bishop
there
now I cannot do this time warning um
that's a chicken fortunately it's out
how to play you this stuff I wanted to
take now which is this is not not great
here check check I hate it I really
hated to spoil those great positions I
had a clearly better position here of
course check or at least this is not
totally clear
you simply does not want to draw rather
noses come on check white fourth it's a
long time ah Wow cool I know what
happens really I know that this is this
is excellent from luck but I didn't I
didn't I couldn't find something here ja
b 6 mm it's what the computer is giving
opening up some line yeah maybe maybe
that's the Blitz the thing I just I just
doubled just doubled him yeah a g6 is of
course yeah I don't want to accept I
have no way to improve him it looks good
but I don't have any tactical blower
anything a computer also doesn't seem
see anything maybe that'd be six move
computer get gave me a good good
advantage but yeah this is now it's
getting just I'm just very tricky now
here king is seven not taking yeah yeah
yeah it is stronger just go here and
black black is ok probably he cannot
move there still because of the pin and
I have ideas like this so wyd will go
here and green g6 yeah so I'm I thought
I was better but maybe I only was better
in that particular moment where b6 was
possible White's position looks to Chad
awkward or looked a tad awkward but
maybe it's not check
bad here I'm losing after Queen B sang I
was really surprised that this wasn't
check just straight losing each for was
good but we were both them low on time
yeah this is this is actually losing
after King f3 the King f3 is its losing
button this this is just a crapshoot I
hope for pre moves but as I could so I
could still play that wow yeah very very
tough game but I'd like to I'd like to
quickly check because I don't I cannot
believe that black it's not bad and this
position so this is what the engine is
giving hmm yeah I mean there is some
point to that if you the problem was
that opening up the position is
difficult and in this this year I i can
i can appreciate ya with maybe the
bishop coming here and i have something
on the B file Bishop c5 a 5 and so on
yeah yeah computer 0.7 is also not not
brilliant I simply didn't didn't believe
um the white set up here okay well
thanks for watching